This always happens.
You get a bunch
of cows together,
and it's moo, moo, moo.
The next thing you know, boom.
They raise the roof.
Howdy, heifers.
This is D News.
I'm Trace.
Dateline January 27, 2014.
A barn in Rasdorf,
Germany containing 90 cows
was rocked by an explosion.
And a buildup of methane
gas was the culprit.
The roof was damaged,
and at least one cow
needed to be treated for burns.
A static charge produced
by a cow massaging machine
set off the methane explosion,
leading this reporter to ask,
what the heck is a
cow massaging machine?
And how can methane cause
such a big explosion?
First, cows produce
a lot of methane.
You've probably heard that it
can be more damaging than CO2.
The planet has 1.5 billion
cows, and they emit methane
as they digest their food
in their four stomachs.
The bacteria living within cows
help them break down the grass,
but create methane, ammonia
and other gases in the process.
Estimates vary,
but experts believe
a single cow can produce
approximately 100 to 500 liters
of methane per day, or
about as much pollution
as the average car.
You might associate methane
gas with fart smell,
but you'd be wrong.
Methane is odorless, colorless.
It's lighter than air.
And it's flammable.
Industry adds sulfur smell
to help identify gas leaks.
But with cow farts, I mean,
they already kind of-- well,
they kind of smell.
Anyway, with 90 cows
in a barn, their butts
could produce as much as 45,000
liters of methane in a day.
That gas would then float
to the top of the barn,
especially if the barn didn't
have proper ventilation.
By some estimates,
methane gas is
combustible at concentrations
as little as 5%.
So without knowing
the size of the barn,
I can't really tell you
much more than that.
But hey, the boom happened.
We know.
Explosions like this happen
more often than you'd think.
Methane is suspected
to have caused
an explosion earlier this year
at a waste water treatment
plant, last August in a
Mexico office building,
and inside a New
Zealand mine in 2010.
This is by far,
however, the stinkiest.
But at least no one was hurt.
Coal miners have to
worry about methane, too.
Rocks contain 100 to 600
cubic feet of methane
for every ton of
coal being mined.
Being lighter than air but
trapped in a mine shaft
means the methane displaces that
air and can cause suffocation.
It's real dangerous, y'all.
But it can also be useful.
Aside from blowing
up German barns,
methane is used as a fuel
to create heat and light
in homes and
commercial buildings.
And then on a larger
scale, methane
can be used to
generate electricity.
87% of natural gas is methane.
It's also used to make
industrial chemicals,
and in the garment, automotive,
and plastics industries.
Most farmers have
specialized barns
that stop methane buildup
by letting it float up
into the atmosphere
out of the barn.
But more enterprising and
environmentally conscious
animal farmers capture
methane to sell as energy.
So, though it can be considered
environmentally harmful,
it can blow up a barn,
it's not entirely useless.
It's actually a rather valuable
gas, when used properly.
So are you worried about cow
farts destroying the planet?
Tell us what you think.
And thanks a lot for
watching D News today.
And, if you're a fan of
animals that can blow stuff up,
Furrocious is a new
show on Animalist
where the cute and
cuddly can kill you.
Do you know what catnip is?
Catnip is bath salts for cats.
So what you're going
to do is you're
going to bring this little
inbred, junkie, carnivorous,
bloodthirsty, freeloading,
disease ridden
beast into our domicile.
And that's why we can't
get a Persian cat.
Check it out on animalist.com,
and subscribe if you like it.
And don't forget
to subscribe here
for more D News videos
every day of the week.